good evening everyone i am priyana
tarajan i'm the current director of the
frankie program in science and the
humanities
and i'm an astrophysicist by training
and i'm a faculty member at yale's
department of physics and the department
of astronomy
so i am delighted uh to welcome you all
to uh this evening's talk which is
part of our ongoing
thematic workshop and study on the
nature of inference understanding the
nature of inference in particular
understanding causation correlation and
understanding these issues from a
multi-disciplinary viewpoint so as many
of you know we've had these monthly
seminars we've had experts pioneers who
have been working on using
machine learning and artificial
intelligence methodologies in their
particular disciplines ranging from
chemistry biology computer science and
physics today
and i am
really happy to introduce today's
speaker who's part of our core team for
this project as well
and uh today's speaker is professor kyle
cranmer who is currently at nyu but
before i give
you an introduction to kyle and his work
i want to say a big thank you to our
benefactors um
richard and barbara frankie who i think
are amongst the audience today their
generosity and support of all the
interdisciplinary activities at yale
multivarious activities and centers that
they support including the frankie
program in science and the humanities uh
has been very very impactful in getting
scholars who are otherwise in silos to
actually collaborate talk and interact
with each other
so um
let me go on now to tell you a little
bit more about our wonderful speaker
kyle is currently a professor of physics
and data science at nyu
and he's a visiting scientist at meta
meta in july he will become the director
for the american family insurance data
science institute at the university of
wisconsin-madison it's their brand new
effort
in data science at madison
he obtained his phd in physics from the
university of miss wisconsin so he's
going back home in a way
in 2005 and he got his ba in mathematics
and physics from rice university
he's a recipient many awards i just
list a few uh he was awarded the
presidential early career award for
science and engineering
the p cass in 2007 the national science
foundation's career award in 2009
and he became a fellow of the american
physical society for his work on the
large hadron collider
so one of the key uh sort of the seminal
contributions that kyle has made
is the development of a framework um
a very robust framework that enables
collaborative statistical modeling and
as you can imagine with the vast amount
of data from the large hadron collider
his work was used extensively for the
discovery of the higgs boson
which as you all know was a major
breakthrough in particle physics
announced in 2012 at cern
so his current interests are at the
intersection of physics statistics and
machine learning and um as you can
probably guess he's one of the pioneers
in uh in our field trying to leverage
these new innovative methods
for
obtaining a deeper understanding of the
physical world
so
before i turn it over to him let me very
quickly remind you that the format of
these talks please feel free to put your
questions um in the
in the chat you have a burning question
um you know do raise your hand something
that requires immediate clarification
otherwise we prefer to have the q a
session after the talk and as you all
know the format of these talks has been
um we first start out with a colloquium
and so which kyle will be giving
followed uh followed by a few days later
uh an actual sort of discussion session
uh in which we have an interlocutor
another expert in the field who
approaches things from a slightly
different vantage point engaging
uh with kyle stock today as well as you
know offering us their own insights and
so we are delighted to have dr zena
tavares who's at columbia who is also
here in the audience today who will be
leading the discussion session and
framing some of the open questions and
engaging with the material that uh kyle
will be um uh presenting today and it
you know these sessions have been
wonderful lively discussions
and uh really look forward to it uh so
zena and kyle will be in conversation
next wednesday um at 4 00 p.m
and to quickly give you a preview of
coming attractions we have carl zimmer
who will be speaking as part of the
distinguished speaker series about his
new book life's edge
and that's at the end of march march
30th and then we have our mapping as
knowing lecture series continuing with
victor coelho in april
and we have a bunch of our own frankie
fellow speaking later on in april anyway
without further ado um let me now turn
it over to kyle kyle we are delighted i
wish we could have hosted you in person
both kyle and zenna but things are as
they are um i think um we're just really
uh grateful and deeply appreciative of
you uh
agreeing to speak to us uh on zoom thank
you
thank you very much priya for the warm
introduction and thank you zena for
agreeing to uh the conversation next
week i'm really looking forward to it um
let me share my screen here hopefully
this is fine
okay does that look good
yep looks great
gonna hide you so i can see a little bit
better
okay
um
so yeah i'm really excited to uh to you
know to be invited in this series it's
been really interesting i've been able
to watch quite a quite a few of the
talks not all of them but uh but i think
most of them as well as the
discussions and conversations that
followed
which i find to be really interesting i
like the format a lot so thank you very
much for having me um i think i am maybe
the last one of this of this particular
slate but maybe they'll be added uh some
more so i tried to take on a little bit
of a role of referring back to some of
the other talks that happened in the
series
um and uh and so the title i chose is uh
causality at the intersection of
simulation inference science and
learning and hopefully be able to see
how all these get tied together
um so i'm gonna start by saying that
there were a few of the talks that
happened earlier where uh causality was
being you know examined and that word
was being used uh in a particular way
that physicists use it um
which has to do for instance with things
like the arrow of time the structure of
space time that's my little diagram here
this sort of uh
this is uh some of whoops gives me uh
some event and you have a future light
cone and a past light cone
and the notion of two events being maybe
separated uh so that they're out of
causal contact with each other and other
points that are in causal contact with
each other uh trying to understand that
in the context of
like i mentioned before the arrow of
time or
in the context of quantum mechanics
et cetera and these were these are very
interesting talks um
but there were some other talks that
were a slightly different uh usage of
the word causation
which is more in the in the language of
sort of causal inference and kind of
from the statistical point of view um so
there you have things like here's my
little picture of a sun
and uh and the sun you know is leading
to hot sunny weather
which kind of causes people eating ice
cream and sunburns
and then that gives rise to some kind of
correlation between ice cream and
sunburns but we would probably all agree
to say it's wrong to say that ice cream
causes sunburns um and so that's the the
typical uh correlation does not cause
the correlation causation aren't the
same thing and so the
the mathematical framework for trying to
think about this and causal reasoning or
sort of the the subject of uh for
instance these two talks
um now after uh the talk by janana
ismail
woodward was uh the
conversant that followed up and i
grabbed a little bit of the transcript
from their conversation because i found
it uh to be very interesting and it's
kind of a nice entry point into what i
wanted to talk about today so james was
pointing out you know in response to the
talk that there were
potentially some interesting
uh you know uh route to be had on on the
philosophical side by thinking uh about
what he talked about a
a component that has a more normative
character
i talked about the procedures that make
causal reasoning or learning causal
relationships from certain kinds of data
reliable
and he said that the sort of normative
aspects of things when you do that then
you bring in the connection with
statistics causal reasoning machine
learning and ai and that it would be
interesting to sort of uh you know see
how these two ways of going about the
general topic relate to each other and
so i'm going to definitely uh sort of
follow up from that a little bit
um
and uh so you know while i am you know
my
core discipline as a physicist i've been
doing a lot of work on machine learning
and ai and a lot of what i you know have
to say kind of comes more on the
statistics side of things but they're of
course very deeply related and so to try
to kind of prime that i'm going to just
give a few of graphic examples so here's
a system um it's a toy that i have on my
desk right now
and when you see this kind of thing you
see the balls bouncing around it sort of
naturally uh you know draws to mind a
probabilistic description of what's
going on and of course thinking about
these kinds of things you know are
really back in the early history of uh
you know our statistics and probability
uh but if you think about the system as
it evolves when you describe it you know
it's natural to think of the balls
bouncing either to the left or to the
right with some probability and so you
have this
probabilistic description where the
system evolves in a stochastic way
and now the same system if you look at
it you know more closely and in slow
motion you see the balls balancing
around and now you're thinking maybe
more like classical mechanics
of a deterministic evolution of a system
where the balls
are balancing through this lattice of of
pins and if you knew uh the initial
state perfectly you know it would unfold
in a totally deterministic way um and uh
and so that kind of points to this other
notion of causation that's more from the
physicist's point of view and things
like the era of time and et cetera now
if we want to try to sort of reconcile
these two different ways of looking at
the same system
we know that this is very you know
sensitive to the initial conditions and
if you slightly perturb
the balls at the very beginning they
would take a different path through the
the lattice of uh pins and so that so
each realization of you know this
turning this desk toy over gives you
effectively some you know random outcome
now this also happens when you for
instance look at uh you know climate
science these are simulations that are
going on
of
you know eddies inside of the oceans um
the the description of this is you know
a fluid mechanic so you have things like
navier-stokes equations again that are
deterministic uh there is some scale at
which you can't resolve what's going on
anymore um and so you have this kind of
chaotic behavior and so there is a
connection again to
um you know randomness and
stochasticity
but it's kind of interesting here the
higher level picture
is kind of looks like deterministic and
then uh but then you have some
lower level information that you can't
resolve so that introduces some
randomness into the system
um and then you have you know you you
have different arrangements of this and
i guess there's just the observation
that as you sort of you know step
through
you know step down the reductionist
ladder or you know maybe step up the uh
the ladder of emergent phenomena um that
you often see switches and whether or
not the kind of effective description
that you're working with looks uh
stochastic or deterministic and i think
that's just kind of an interesting
observation so for instance when you're
talking about thermodynamics or
thermostatics you have you know pressure
and volume and these kinds of quantities
um and there are equations that relate
them and it looks much more
deterministic
but we you know then understand
thermodynamics is very
arising from an underlying uh
statistical mechanical description of
what's going on
um and then here kind of flipping the
roses around this is supposed to be the
two-slit experiment and at the top you
see
for instance
uh you know electrons hitting some
screen or something like that and the
individual electrons are like point-like
particles and they have a random nature
that's associated with the kind of
randomness of quantum mechanics but at
the same time when we think of a kind of
underlying deterministic evolution of
the wave function you know due to
schrodinger's equation so this is just
basically the prime that the two
different ways of thinking about
causality and deterministic systems and
stochastic systems are
you know very closely related
i'm going to be talking um more about
stochastic systems but just keep in mind
that you you know this this relationship
now in the conversation uh that i
alluded to before later on um you know
about
a half an hour into the discussion
um james uh pointed out again that this
this important uh uh topic of called
scale separation which is essentially
the observation that if you wanted to
describe a bulldozer you don't need to
bring in quantum you know quantum
mechanics or quantum chromodynamics uh
to try to describe that and he says you
know you could imagine an alternative
world where to basically model anything
you have to you know model all the way
down to the you know the most detailed
way but but the uh but that doesn't seem
how to be like how our world is arranged
and that we often see some kind of
approximate decoupling between the
different scales and that facilitates uh
causal reasoning in our world and i i
100 agree with that and i'm going to
sort of uh you know show some examples
of that
so now moving on to the kind of
you know the topic of the series is
inference and of course it's it's
related to causation and correlation
um and so the way that i'm going to you
know be talking about it is that you
know in the context of some scientific
theory uh for instance as a particle
physicists we have theories uh and those
theories often have some parameters that
call those theta and then i can use that
theory to make predictions about what i
will see in a particular experiment and
that uh and so i'm making predictions
about the data uh
which i call x here and the the process
of inference is sort of the inverse of
that from some data i would like to
infer something about the
the theory that i that's in question
um and that can be done in various
different ways um
you know
often it's phrased in the context of
bayesian inference where
you if you want to say something about
probabilistic about a theory given some
data uh via bayes theorem you can relate
that to a statement about the
probability of the data given the theory
so this is this is what's called the
likelihood function um and uh and then
times a prior probability for the theory
now in particle physics i'll just make a
quick comment that the prior probability
for the theory is a very
thorny thorny thing it's not like uh you
know what's the prior probability that
you uh uh you know have the flu or
something before you you you you have
coveted before you uh take a covet test
uh here you're talking about like you
know does some fundamental particle
exist in the universe or not
and it's hard to talk about that in a
probabilistic way other than through
more like subjective notions of uh
belief
um but this term the likelihood function
is is sort of very well grounded and uh
and how we as physicists you know take a
theory and turn that into predictions
about what we expect the data to look
like and i'm not going to get into the
the issues of bayesian versus
frequentest
statistics really other than just to
point out it's an issue the main thing
i'm going to be focusing on here uh is
the details and difficulties with the
probability of the data given the theory
or the likelihood function um and uh and
so i'll come back to that later but this
is sort of roughly the probabilistic way
in which i'll be just discussing
inference
now uh this is a picture of a of an
actual collision that happened in uh
2012 and on the 10th of june um at the
large hadron collider and the atlas
experiment that i work on um and
obviously it's a computer you know a
rendering of an actual collision that
happened in the data um i'll talk about
it a little bit in some more detail in a
moment this was one of approximately a
quadrillion collisions of the large
hadron collider that happened in those
uh in a couple years uh so there were
you know there were many many collisions
like this but this was this one was one
that was particularly important because
it was a candidate uh for being
consistent with the production of the
higgs boson
um so we had more collisions that were
were like that and we did some
statistical analysis of the data which
i'll say a little bit more about and
that's what led to you know the claim of
the discovery in july of 2012. and one
of the things that's interesting about
this is this really within about a week
of that
was one of the kind of breakthrough
milestone papers and deep learning and
that's when we really started seeing
deep learning as we think of it today
uh in the context of uh image analysis
image classification uh really starting
to work quite well
and you know very shortly after this you
started getting situations where uh you
know deep neural networks were
you know sort of claims of superhuman
performance and things like this so
so this was definitely a miles milestone
moment both from the point of view of
deep learning and from particle physics
and for me personally
right after this i went on sabbatical
and that's kind of i really shifted my
my focus to thinking about how to put
these two together how can we take
advantage of what's going on in machine
learning and deep learning uh for the
purposes of doing science and what does
that relationship look like
um and this was interesting
because it's kind of the backdrop of a
you know a debate that's happening
across all the sciences where you see a
pendulum swinging essentially from you
know in the context of physics you had
traditional approaches to analyzing the
data where you have more handcrafted
types of data analysis largely guided by
expert knowledge and theoretical insight
switching over to something that's
really started you know you know even a
decade or more before with
the rise of big data and data science
and deep learning and there's a you know
a push to
be ever more data driven uh uh in the
context of machine learning you use this
phrase end-to-end learning uh and that
basically is hinting at uh sort of
eschewing expert knowledge uh and uh and
and what sometimes referred to as a uh
you know hand-designed features and
things like this and really try to have
an end-to-end system driven by you know
with some
deep neural network or something in the
middle that tries to go from the data
directly to solving your problem so that
would be something like data from the
lhc to yes you discovered the higgs or
not like in one step
um and so that's a very different
approach
and this is paired with the kind of
desire that maybe ai is somehow like
magical and it's just going to look at
all the data and figure things out and
it's again paired with a discussion that
started really with big data
about uh these kinds of i would take so
some are ridiculous claims that uh that
we're looking at the end of theory and
that the data deluge makes the
scientific method obsolete uh quotes
like this that uh all models are wrong
and increasingly you can succeed without
them um and uh
and you know given everything that's
going on it's hard to just dismiss these
claims because something is happening
you know but uh but so that's partially
what we want to look into a little bit
more deeply is uh you know to what
degree is is this uh are we witnessing
some kind of radical change and the
scientific method uh and and uh what
does that look like
um so i'm gonna switch now to uh kind of
uh you know contrast what i was just
saying on the on the big data side uh
with the go back to the more traditional
approach
um and then start to bring in elements
of causation and and i'll also say that
while physicists are very comfortable
with talking about causation and the
sense of uh
you know space and time and uh
and
and these kinds of things
oftentimes we are not particularly well
trained in the in the language of causal
inference uh and things like this it's
actually something that's very core for
instance in the social sciences and in
medical sciences and sometimes in
particle physics or other areas of
physics the causal relationship is so
obvious that it's not really something
that you needed to develop a sort of
calculus to understand
and so in that way we're playing
catch-up but at the same time a lot of
the success of physicists has been based
on leveraging causality notions of
causality
and so that's a kind of interesting
thing to try to reconcile it's partially
what i'm you know thinking about a lot
these days so this is a picture with me
and yuda pearl who who wrote this book
of why
and one of the uh in in his book and
in his writings he he talks about what
he calls the latter of causation
and he's saying the lowest rung of the
ladder uh is uh is association so that's
really at the level of like correlations
um and so uh what you see is sort of
seeing and observing where you're uh
where you just have data basically and
and the point here is that there are a
set of questions that you can address
when you have a lot of data but there
are other types of questions that you
cannot address
just with data so the idea that the you
know big data is going to solve all your
problems is really only restricted to
this lowest wrong on the ladder and in
fact there are higher level questions
where you want to ask questions like you
know what would happen if i do the
following if you intervene on the system
and those kinds of questions cannot be
answered
just through data alone they really
require
essentially some other kind of structure
that you add to it usually in the form
of some kind of assumption um and and i
will give a concrete example in just a
moment
but before doing so i'll just say that
there's even a higher level of question
which are referred to as counter
factuals where you're imaginings
in your you're sort of answering
questions like what would have happened
if i had done the following um and uh
and so that's interesting because uh
you're sort of conditioning on things
that actually happen so you kind of in
principle can't answer that question
because it already happened while in the
context of interventions you could make
the interventions and actually see what
happens right
so um so these are the three levels and
they do have a a very grounded formal
mathematical basis which i'm not going
to go into but just to say that they're
not squishy concepts they're really very
for formalized well-defined
concepts
so let me give a concrete example
this is here you see some some code
so there's three very short little
computer programs where you have random
variables x and y and here you also have
a random variable z
and then there's a little drawing
associated to it so here the story is
that the random variable x was first and
then it sort of causes y and you see in
the program x is was generated through
the random number generator first and
then y depends on x so this is the
direction of causation
uh here you see the opposite y is
generated first and then x is generated
and it's a function of y
um and then finally you have a different
situation where z which is not you know
a
z is the third variable uh that's that's
generated and then y and x both depend
on z
okay fine so uh and here's the little
drawing uh associated to that now what's
the why is this interesting the reason
that this is interesting is here is
there's three different stories about
how the data came to be the data
generating process
but all three of them give you exactly
the same joint distribution
or the correlations between x and y are
exactly the same in these three
different stories
so in that sense if you just had data
you wouldn't be able to answer which of
these three is responsible for producing
the data
but if uh if you can do interventions if
you can go in there and like poke inside
the system and for instance uh set the
variable x to be a
particular value and that's the the
the notation here is do x uh the do
operator means you're going and
intervening and
if it was a simulator if it was a
simulator what you would do is you just
at every step of the program you just
make sure x is equal to three
so you just see extra lines stuck in
there where you force x to be three and
if you do that the you know then if you
look at the data that comes out of this
thing uh x will be three no surprise
there but the distribution of y will be
different in these different cases
and so that points to the fact that if
you can do interventions you can answer
a richer set of questions than you can
if you look at just uh
data alone okay so so you need to be
able to make those kinds of
interventions
and i'll come back to that later okay so
that is you know all a little bit of a
preamble and now i'm going to switch to
a topic which uh is sort of you know
near and dear to my heart which i refer
to as a simulation based imprints so i'm
going to try to sort of set it up
broadly give a feel for
why it's important um and you know tie
it back to some you know specific
examples in physics and then later we'll
uh you know go back to kind of science
and uh and machine learning and
causation and things like that
okay so the first uh you know slide in
in this this section is the starts with
the observation that science is replete
with high fidelity stimulations
okay so uh we have simulators for our
particle colliders at the large hadron
collider we have simulations for
neuronal activity
we have
simulations for how epidemics spread we
have simulations for gravitational
lensing and evolution of the universe on
the largest scales we have stimulators
for how air you know moves around an
airplane which we use to design
airplanes and simulations for how
proteins will fold and things like that
which helps us into the design of drugs
and etc and these simulators what's
interesting about them is not only can
you use them to generate synthetic data
um they are causal models uh for how the
data generating process of the data
generating process they actually have
some mechanism of you know what you
think is happening right so in the case
of
of uh you know proteins you have atoms
and molecules and there may be you know
surrounded by water bumping into them
and you have energy you know
uh for you know some arrangement and and
the system evolves in a certain way for
epidemics you have individual people
maybe that you're modeling and they may
get sick or not with some probability
and that system evolves in some way and
so um and so you can imagine in that
simulator for instance intervening like
what happened if i like held on to the
protein and pulled it in a certain way
what would happen
or in epidemics you could do a
simulation of what would happen if
everyone got a vaccine for instance so
um
so the the the fact that they're causal
is very important
and now uh
as you'll see throughout the talk
there's a kind of computational you know
bent to a lot of the way that i'm
thinking about things and so uh it's
important to recognize that the you know
the expressiveness of programming
languages and the and the you know
modern computing and all of this allows
us to really scale this up and actually
simulate uh you know these very
complicated systems uh and and make some
very high fidelity simulations and uh
that's something you know that's a
capability we didn't have you know 50
years ago and so
so this is definitely changing the way
that we do science um but as you'll see
in a second it's a little bit out of
step with the way that we approach uh
statistics currently
and so that's the point here basically
is that unfortunately these simulators
while they produce very high fidelity
simulated data are poorly suited for
statistical inference and so why is that
well let me try to give you some feel
for why that is so before doing that i'm
just going to lay out a little bit of
notation
so i talked earlier about on the left
side here i have basically the theory
it has some parameters which i'm calling
theta
and those might be for instance
in the cases of covet or something it
might be like how virulent is this new
virus uh you know how quickly does it uh
does it double as it you know goes
through the population or it could be a
parameter like the cosmological constant
of the universe or the mass of the higgs
boson
what have you so you have these kinds of
parameters over here
and then the simulator allows you to
make predictions for the observed data
it's not going to just be the observed
data is not going to have a particular
value it's going to be have many
possible values so it's going to
describe a probability distribution over
the observed data
but inside the simulation
there might also be other random
variables that are referred to as latent
variables
which
are you know part of the story of how
the data came to be even though you
might not be able to actually observe
them in your experiment so i'll give
some examples
but you could imagine that for instance
in the case of covid
x might just be like hospitalization
rates or something like that or people
uh you know testing you know how many
people tested positive with covid the
latent variable would be something like
how many people actually have coved you
know you don't know that uh but if
you're doing a simulation you would have
access to that that variable right right
so um so then the the question of this
inverse problem or of inference is to go
from the data x to say the parameters of
interest uh theta
now
here's that same uh uh desk toy um now
i'm just going to i don't know if you
can see it here's the actual toy uh if i
you can imagine i want to introduce some
notion of our parameter so let's say i
tilt the toy to the left or i tilt the
toy to the right you know if i if i tilt
it one way it's going to bias the
distribution
so that you know it doesn't look the
same so
imagine that i want to try to infer this
parameter theta which is say like how
tilted the
the whole toy is
i could relate that maybe with the
probability that a ball bounces to the
right
and so that's the thing that i want to
infer and i'm going to do that based on
the distribution of where the balls land
at the bottom
and i'm going to call the the location
where they land at the bottom x
and then the latent variable would be
the path that the balls took through
this lattice of nails okay and you know
in principle i could maybe go observe
that but i wasn't paying any attention
it was too fast so really all i get to
observe is where they landed um and i'm
going to think of the path that they
took as the latent variable
so if you want to predict what is that
distribution um well you might say okay
well i can do that it's either going to
bounce to the left or to the right with
some probability
there's many possible paths but there's
some nice symmetry that's that's there
and and if you took your combinatorics
class uh then you can figure out what
that distribution should look like and
and there it is at the bottom that's the
binomial distribution okay um so you
would assume this is the binomial
distribution as i i did once before
teaching a class on the subject to
undergraduates
but then i compared that to
what it actually looks like and it
doesn't match up and then i was a little
confused as to why and then i took the
slow-motion video that i showed you
before and if you look closely you'll
see that the balls are not just going
left and right they're they're bouncing
all over the place sometimes they skip
over two or three uh pins they run into
each other
you know it's a lot more complicated
right
so if you want to say what's the
distribution here down at the bottom you
know i have no idea what that
distribution is but i can simulate it
and that's that's kind of you know part
of the point um so here's an example of
a simulation for this exact thing done
by my colleague guinea spiden um and uh
i know it looks very realistic it looks
a lot like that video i just showed you
you don't know exactly how bouncy the
balls are how big the nails the pins are
etcetera but but you can simulate it and
symbolically if you if you ask yourself
what's the probability distribution that
the data you know of the data landing in
these different bins uh at the bottom uh
given the parameter that says like how
tilted it is symbolically it's equal to
you know don't be worried about the math
too much this integral just means i'm
going to sum over all the possible
trajectories that the balls could take
that would give you that same
observation
the problem now is that i can't do that
some with us nice mathematical tricks of
combinatorics
um because i there's no like nice
structure anymore to take advantage of
and this latent space of different
possibilities is growing rap very very
rapidly
and so that means that basically this
integral that i want to perform where i
sum over all the different paths is now
intractable
and that means that the likelihood the
thing that relates the probability of
the data given the parameters is not
available to me anymore in any practical
sense
and so here i would say that the
likelihood is intractable and that means
that basically all of the different
approaches for doing uh statistical
inference require that you have the
likelihood and so like what do you do
now basically
um so while that the likelihood is
intractable i can still generate
synthetic observations with my simulator
and so it seems like you should be able
to make some kind of progress by
basically comparing the outcome of the
simulations to the actual data and so
then the question is just how are you
going to do that in practice
so let me go back to the large hadron
collider and tell a slight the same
story but with a more you know
complicated real you know real world
science experiment um so here's the very
complicated data at the large hadron
collider
it's very high dimensional
um you know the the detector has about a
hundred thousand sensors on it um
and so when i want to make a prediction
of what will happen i start off with a
theory which is you know based on
quantum mechanics and quantum field
theory that we call the standard model
it has some parameters
i can then uh use that theory i don't
know maybe you've seen things like
feynman diagrams sort of pictorial
representations that allow me to
calculate
what would happen you know what's the
probability that the particles are going
to scatter off of each other in a
certain way and that this interaction
will take place this interaction has a
higgs boson in it that decays into some
other particles called z's that decay
into other things it doesn't really
matter but these these particles over
here on the right are coming flying out
into the detector the problem is that we
don't see those directly uh instead
there's another process where they
radiate and it becomes really messy um
and i can and at this stage i can't
write down what's going on like really
on a pencil and paper uh i can describe
what happens kind of locally every time
you see one of these splittings i can
write down a probability but the whole
process is this very complicated uh you
know
thing and so i can put it on a computer
but it's very difficult to work with
with a pencil and paper
so you go from the latent variables
that were
associated with this first stage
followed by latent variables random
variables that i don't get to observe
followed with this complicated showering
process is what it's called then these
particles are physical particles that
come flying and smash into our detectors
and they ionize and they you know run
into you know pieces of metal and they
do all the things that they do
um and then there are there are
literally hundreds of millions of latent
variables associated with uh how these
particles interact with our gargantuan
detectors
um and finally you get observe you know
observed you know electronic signals in
our detector which is like the raw data
that is collected by these experiments
and so that's x
and so if i want to think about how do i
simulate that um you know i just told
you the physical story there's actually
software for each one of these stages
and you can think of these different
programs as basically encoding these
probability distributions they go from
one step to the next step the next step
and it's really kind of hopping
you know from the smallest scales to the
next scale to the next scale in some
probabilistic way until you get to the
final observations and we call these uh
monte carlo generators and that's
because monte carlo is a technique that
you can see as a way of trying to
integrate
these random variables so symbolically
you could write down the simulation
this way you're saying basically the
likelihood of the observations given the
data is equal to this integral of this
you know these this product of
probabilities but this integral is like
100 million dimensional and there's no
way that you're going to do that
basically like this is a totally
intractable integral uh in practice so
um so that means that the likelihood is
intractable here
so
so what do you do like how is it that we
discovered the higgs boson if we're in
this kind of setting right
um so what we what we have done as a
field for decades and other fields have
kind of developed their own version of
this uh ranging from genomics to
cosmology to uh you know all over the
place is that you use your kind of
domain knowledge your expert knowledge
to think about like well what is it
about the data that's going to be useful
for testing the hypothesis that i have
in mind
um and and that turns into basically in
the context of the particle physics
taking very high dimensional data from
the detector
and then distilling
you know 100 million electronic sensor
readouts into just one number which is
the horizontal axis in this plot
which i'm going to then make a histogram
of
and and i'm going to histogram the data
so every collision i have just one
number and i have many collisions so i
get build a histogram and that's like
the black dots in the histogram and the
red histogram is basically what i
predict from my theory
and and the important part is that i can
sort of fill that histogram up with a
bunch of simulations
so
if i step back and like look at the text
on the slide here um the in a
statistical language you would say this
one variable that distills all the
information from this high dimensional
data is called a summary statistic
that's what a
statistician will call it sometimes it's
related to feature engineering is what a
machine learning person might call it
and the the you know coming up with this
summary uh quantity is basically the
task of a skilled physicist and then we
try to estimate the distribution of the
summary statistic here are these like
histograms using just something simple
like a histogram
um so if we look at this picture of this
collision that i showed you earlier with
a which was you know a
candidate for the higgs boson we have
this very high dimensional data you know
how what does the process look like that
we take this high dimensional data and
we distill it into a single number
well the first part we kind of take for
granted you know like you can see in the
picture there are these for instance
these four red lines
uh you know if you ask a particle
physicist they'll say oh these are four
muons
uh that were reconstructed from the
particular signals that they leave
inside of the detector uh because muons
have this interesting property that they
can you know punch their way all the way
through you know all of this material
you know there's like
several meters of lead and iron and etc
so they can go all the way through that
but they ionize on their way out and
that leaves a little trace of energy
deposits along the way and so we can see
those energy deposits and then we can
identify them and then say yes we think
there was a muon here we can say if it
was a positive or negatively charged one
we can estimate its energy in its
direction and then that's basically all
there is to say about that muon um
and so then in this example we have four
of them
so we don't you know there's already
lots of philosophical questions here
about like do you how do you know that
that's the muon you don't really see the
muon you see the energy deposits in the
detector uh but you know this this
concept of a muon has served physicists
very well we see muons and all sorts of
different experiments and we can predict
what they're going to look like and
that's exactly what we see in the data
so physicists generally believe that the
idea of muons are real right so um so if
i take these these four muons that's
great maybe i can sort of see them and
my detector uh but what about the higgs
well if i produced a higgs in this
uh in this collision it would have
decayed instantaneously uh and never
even made it to you know the next atom
over uh before it decays so um so we're
never going to see the higgs boson in
our detector directly
so so why how do we know if we made a
higgs
well um we want to try to somehow
basically sequentially invert the causal
process of how the data came to be so
first we identified these muons and now
we want to think about okay well where
did the muons come from
um
and so and then we're going to exploit
things that we know like uh relativity
so uh so maybe you're familiar with e
equals m c squared uh you know that's
not really what einstein said uh that
only kind of works if nothing's moving
um if something is moving then you can
sort of square both sides and add an
extra component that has to do with the
momentum so you say the energy is
related to the mass and the momentum
through this equation
um and but i don't see the higgs
particle so you know how do i use this
equation well you can take advantage of
energy and momentum conservation so if
there was a higgs that was produced the
energy that it had was kind of like the
energy beforehand turns into the energy
after which is the energy that i would
have in those four muons
and uh similarly the momentum for the
higgs is the momentum before turns in
the momentum after turns into the sum of
the momentum and those four muons
so i can take this equation and this
equation and put them together and
rearrange it and basically if i'm
producing higgs bosons and the higgs
bosons have a well-defined mass then
this particular
combination of things should basically
always give me the same number up to
like measurement uncertainties
so um so let's see what it looks like in
the data
that's this quantity that i just told
you for every collision i calculate that
equation i just showed you and i get a
particular number and i histogram it and
then i can do that with both real data
that's those are the black dots and then
i can do it with simulated data so if i
take the simulation of what i expect
from uh you know normal uh processes
that i already know about uh in particle
physics i expect the blue histogram
that's sort of sitting on top of this
green histogram and that's basically
plays the role of our null hypothesis
that's what we expect to see if there is
no higgs particle
and these are the little finemen
diagrams that correspond to those
processes
but if i'm producing the higgs i expect
to see something else i have a new
process and so i expect to see a bump
sitting on top of it
and so that's the prediction and you see
there's this very sharp feature in the
data this very sharp bump
and uh the fact that it's a sharp
feature is important um and the reason
that you know the way that i was able to
use my domain knowledge to take the very
complicated from the lhc data and and
come up with this very sharp feature is
like a testament to what you know
physicists uh you know are good at right
so um and so as you can already see the
data look like they prefer a bump and as
we collected more and more data the
evidence for the bump became very
obvious
and that is the basically the the
experimental signature that we found the
higgs
but we didn't just do that in the one
example that i showed you this one we
did it across
literally hundreds of different ways
that you might expect to see the higgs
particle in lhc data and they're all
related to each other and this is where
this collaborative statistical modeling
framework that prio alluded to uh you
know came to came into to play um and
this is just a graph of the like the
computer like the the computer program
that we use to calculate the probability
of the data given the print you know the
parameters it's pretty complicated but
it's really like classical statistics
um and the fact that we're able to
relate all of these different kinds of
you know parts of the data is again like
shows the strength of the fact that our
theory has this causal nature that
allows us to relate all of these
different parts of the data together
um so then we you know we analyzed this
and uh unsurprisingly uh we you know we
found the higgs and we reclaimed the
discovery
um so i showed you this picture before
the slide previously um so that we took
the high dimensional data and we you
know boiled it down into the summary
statistic
and this has worked pretty well so this
is an example of simulation based
inference
where this histogram the red histogram
is basically playing the role you know
it's approximating the probability of
the data given the theory and i can
calculate that from simulations
the problem with this approach though is
it does not work well if you don't have
a really good summary statistic and if
you want to for instance work with like
more like the raw data or your summary
is like a higher dimensional thing
then this approach is not going to scale
now basically you you're never going to
have enough simulated data to make a
high dimensional histogram
and that's related to this thing called
the cursive dimensionality
so um
so this is so that's a bit of a problem
um
and so the interesting thing that's
happening right now
which is using machine learning in some
sense in a very traditional way
is uh you know since you can use your
simulator to produce a lot of synthetic
data it's a very good match for machine
learning and what people have figured
out how to do and i've made some
contributions here myself is figure out
how can we use the simulated data and
then the value of the parameters that we
you know that we know because we use
them when we ran the simulator to try to
get a neural network or something else
some other kind of machine learning
model to effectively approximate the
likelihood or the likelihood ratio or
the posterior one of these statistical
objects that we need for doing inference
and basically it's just a way of getting
around this intractable integral that i
referred to earlier and so in that sense
it's very practical
but it's also very profound because it's
giving us like really like superpowers
across all sorts of different areas of
science and it's happening like right
now and i think it's like a very uh
important profound moment and the like
evolution of statistics
previously there were really big jumps
that happened in statistics when you
went from having to solve uh problems
with just pencil and paper and using
calculus you know like you know
to where you could for instance uh if
you didn't know how to find the minimum
or a maximum of a function you could use
a numerical optimizer or if you didn't
know how to integrate something you know
like with a pencil and paper you could
use numerical integration uh you know
techniques
now we're at the point where the
likelihood function itself is not
tractable and we're able to use machine
learning to basically uh fill in that
gap and give us a good approximation of
the of the likelihood which then allows
us to go back and do uh to do kind of
classical statistical inference um so
this is a really important
important point um and it's allowing
like you know scientists of various uh
stripes to be able to uh work kind of
directly with the low-level raw data uh
maybe not have some good insight about
like what is a good summary
uh but you're not throwing away your
expert knowledge your expert knowledge
is in the simulator and you're using
machine learning as a way of basically
transferring the expert knowledge from
the simulator onto the surrogate which
is some sort of neural network or
something and so uh so it's you know
again i'd say it's all very practical
but it has you know profound
implications
okay so um yeah so if i step back a
little bit and say you know they're you
know think about what's going on you
know as i mentioned before there are all
these areas of science that have these
well-motivated mechanistic models that
are that are their simulators
machine learning is basically providing
an ability to effectively gap uh
bridge the gap between
some low-level microscopic phenomena
that interact in some way that's you
know intractable
to some effective statistical model for
some higher level quantities some other
higher level phenomena and so it's kind
of you know like the more like a
emergent phenomena
and you're able to bridge those two in
some effective way and so i think that
uh if you want to be able to do this
reliably there's a question of like how
much simulated data do you need and this
is where you know sometimes if you don't
have a smart way of doing it this is
where it's going to require an enormous
amount of simulated data and this whole
approach is doomed to failure
but if there if there is something that
makes this work
um then that's important and and uh and
that you know part of the secret sauce
here is essentially causality and this
is where i think it connects to what
james woodward referred to as the more
normative aspects about relating
causality and causal inference
okay so i'm looking at the time here i
realize i'm
going slower than i had uh intended
hopefully for the benefit of clarity um
but uh
but okay so i'm gonna switch a little
bit uh and uh don't be alarmed if i kind
of skip over a few slides so um
okay
so uh so what i just talked about was
sort of one part of kind of the bigger
scientific method this is one of these
kind of toy
uh you know drawings of the scientific
method which is you know
i don't really believe the scientific
method has a flow chart associated to it
but if there if there is one i prefer
this one compared to the other ones that
i find with a google search
but the the thing that i wanted to focus
on here is that
this part about gathering data and
testing predictions
that's essentially the part that i was
just describing
we're using machine learning to enable
statistical inference essentially for
doing hypothesis testing
okay and so that you know so you can
either see it testing predictions or
maybe it's about rejecting a hypothesis
so it's kind of isolated to this part of
this flow chart uh nowhere in there is
there a part that's about uh you know
thinking of interesting questions
formulating hypotheses
uh developing testable predictions
trying to figure out what experiments
should you do
all of those parts of the scientific
method are not
not reflected in what i just described
at all
so if you want to try to incorporate
them you know
what is that going to look like right
so here is where you kind of start to
connect to other ideas and machine
learning that are more closely related
to what's called like reinforcement
learning so maybe you're aware of the
news that happened uh surprisingly this
was six years ago today march 9 2016 is
when uh one of these alphago one of
these reinforcement learning deep neural
network type approaches um was able to
beat uh leucidal and and and a game of
go
um and if you think about what's
happening there's there's an iterative
type of interaction between sort of the
the ai agent in some environment which
is like the the opponent and the go
board and the ai agent is trying to
decide what you know what move to to
make next
and this looks a little bit like you
know here in reinforcement learning you
have an agent it takes some action
interacts with the environment and then
there's some sort of updated state
and maybe you get the agent gets a
reward which would be something like are
they in a better position
on the border or not
um but this looks a lot like for
instance a scientist if that your
scientist is the agent trying to decide
what experiment should i perform next
and then when they actually decide that
they interact with the environment which
is actually like performing the
experiment gathering data then the
interpreter is basically the statistical
analysis and this updated state is
essentially for instance like the
bayesian update from your prior
knowledge to your posterior belief right
um and so um so this is kind of a nice
like schematic of what uh
what uh you know experimentation looks
like that connects with the machine
learning
um and this can all be formalized i'm
not gonna go through this but uh but
this is the formalizing it in the
language of statistical decision theory
you see things like states of nature
types of observations what kind of
actions you want to take and again you
see these normative normative
concepts like loss functions and risk
and all of these kinds of things and
then you can basically you know evaluate
how well a particular strategy is
working or not
so
um
so if you wanted to design a new
experiment you might say that like i
debate the thing that i'm going to use
to decide which experiment to perform
next or which intervention i want to
perform is the one that is going you
know an expectation
is going to move me from my you know
prior
degree of belief to a posterior degree
of belief where the information gain is
maximized and you can formalize all of
that in these equations not so important
um and uh oh but i should say what is
important is the the way that the fact
that you're able to answer this question
like what do i expect would happen if i
do a certain intervention the only way
you can answer a question like that is
if you have a causal model and so
because the simulator is a causal model
i can actually answer this question
um and then if you look the different
quantities that pop up in here you know
priors and posteriors if you have a
simulator then you get back into the
situation where the likelihood is
intractable but you can take advantage
of these simulation-based different
things to try to incorporate the two and
do experimental design
so here's a bit of a flow chart if i
want to do experimental design where i'm
sort of trying to optimize the expected
information gain of my next experiment
i sort of do an experiment
i get some data i use bayes theorem to
update my prior to a posterior and then
i want to optimize what's my next
experiment going to look like so that's
some you know some loop that i do and
what does it look like you know it you
can go through it but basically now you
you sort of do the same thing that's on
the left but with simulated data uh
you expect you know that you would see
if you do a certain intervention which
you can calculate because you have a
simulator but this becomes there's like
a it's just very very expensive
computationally to do this because you
have
all this uh simulations inside of loops
inside of loops and so uh
computationally this is just you know
it's doable but it's very very expensive
um now i i prototyped this with some
some colleagues
and we were able to get a system that
could basically optimize you know what
beam energy should you use for a
particle collider if you want to measure
one of the particular quantities inside
of
uh you know the standard model called
the the weak mixing angle or the
weinberg angle
and uh and you can do that and it
basically says okay the expected
information gain as a function of the
center of mass energy looks something
like this
and this agrees with what you expect if
you're a you know if you've got a phd in
particle physics this is probably some
problem that you had to do for homework
at some point but what's interesting is
a graduate student can look at the
equations and can just reason through it
without any of this computation and say
yes you should run you know like roughly
this energy that's where you're going to
learn the most and that's exactly what
the experimentalist did right so so it's
cool that you can operationalize this
whole thing with machine learning but
it's very inefficient and uh and and you
know somehow humans have been able to do
this much more efficiently
so after i put this together you know i
tweeted about it daniel or zinda who's a
well-known machine learning researcher i
was like oh that's cool you've got the
whole scientific method and a you know
and a python notebook and it's it's half
true but it's you know it's really in
the most confined
you know uh pristine case possible the
simulator is well specified the space of
experimental configurations is very well
specified and still it was hard to do so
i guess what i would draw attention to
is if you want to be able to do
something like this and like humans do
in an open world of possible
experimental configurations and you also
want to include hypothesis generation
and things like this you know modern ai
is very far away from being able to do
that but that's interesting right like
that's the path that we want to to go
down
um
okay so um so
yeah so going back to this kind of
overall big picture about the scientific
method
i think you know if we want to get to
this point where we're we have ai type
systems that are actually designing
experiments formulating hypotheses we're
missing some you know it's not going to
be some end-to-end learning deep neural
network that has no structure it's going
to i think need to have components that
you can point to that are organized in
some way that looks like some kind of
causal structure and it may not have the
same kind of ontology that current
physicists have but maybe some foreign
ontology but i think it's going to need
to have some ontology of different kinds
of components that's
at its essence causal and uh and that
it's gonna need to be able to manipulate
them you know effectively uh if it's
going to do you know science uh in a you
know in any kind of reasonable way and i
think thinking through that is really
important for us trying to like
put our finger on what is it about
causality that's important and to what
degree are we kind of
should we expect that this like this
future ai system is going to arrive at
an ontology that sort of maps one to one
onto the ontology that physicists have
with electrons and muons and exposons
and things like that you know maybe not
but it would be kind of uh it would be a
little bit surprising i would say if it
didn't if it
really didn't if there wasn't some
correspondence there
okay so um yeah so this is just kind of
an editorial note that you know if you
think about how humans do this it's
pretty amazing and when i think you know
when i introspect onto myself as a
physicist you know i definitely have
roughly five or so different mental
models for you know for experimental
particle physics that i you know bounce
between
at different scales and and i choose the
one
excuse me that's appropriate for a given
task and that's how i do physical
reasoning and i have a very hard time
seeing how something that's only working
at the low level of a simulator you know
with uh you know you know tracking the
microscopic trajectories of particles
ionizing off of atoms is going to be
able to cope with the with you know the
kinds of problems that a human does that
can just quickly jump to a very like
stick figure like picture of what's
going on um and i think that you know ai
models are going to need to get to that
point
so in my last couple of minutes i'm just
going to flash a few things that are a
view from the machine learning and ai
community to basically try to uh
you know say that the this line of
thinking is not uh foreign to the ai and
machine learning community uh which you
know i to some degree i'm a part of
myself now
um but but just some concepts that are
floating around in that discussion so
one of them there's a something called
the no free lunch theorem which
basically says that if you if you don't
make any assumptions and you imagine all
the possible
like machine learning problems that you
might have like all the possible data
distributions that essentially there is
no
you know every algorithm is going to
perform equally well to every other
algorithm on average so if one algorithm
is doing better than another it somehow
has to be leveraging something that's
you know atypical um and so if you look
think about say images
you know if you don't add any structure
you know something on the left here
that's the typical image you know it's
just some random noise right that's what
most images look like that
but natural images don't look like that
at all they have all sorts of structure
and smoothness and all sorts of things
going on
and it's uh so the effectiveness of like
you know convolutional neural networks
and things has something to do with the
fact that they're exploiting the
structure that's that's uh of actual
natural images uh and otherwise you know
you know things like cursive
dimensionality you would you would
naively think that it should basically
never work
um stefan malott is a well-known
researcher did work with wavelets and
things like that so he's talking about
you know learning physics with deep
neural networks and points to
two really central pillars if you want
to hope that this is going to work and
one of them is finding symmetries and
the other one is separating phenomena at
different scales so we've already seen
that a few different times and the
convolutional neural networks uh you
know they incorporate both of these uh
both of these ideas
um they're the broader you know class of
these types of ways of adding something
to the model so that it will work are
referred to as inductive bias it's
biased in the sense that it's biasing
towards to be effective towards data of
a certain type you know that has certain
characteristics
and it's maybe not going to help in
other situations
um so here you see scale separation
symmetry the idea of compositionality
the idea of relationships between
different objects and causality these
are i think some of the most important
forms of inductive bias
you see peter like peter battaglia who's
a deep mind now and was previously with
josh 10 obama company and has a
background in human and cognitive
science talking about model building
combinatorial generalization uh sort of
the infinite use of finite means um and
about you know these kinds of ideas
about intelligence and model building
he's taken these ideas to do really
impressive work that have to do with uh
like you're you're in you're interested
in studying some physical system and
you're going to come up with a neural
network architecture that that has some
uh some structure associated to it
that's kind of a mirror of what you
think the actual physical system looks
like i've worked with him on some of
these projects i think it's a very
promising direction
um and then you see
stephanie who's at
mit
talking about a more formal version of
the same idea
she calls it algorithmic alignment and
she has some formal theorems and things
but it's a some approach to try to
formalize this idea of inductive bias
sorry about the street noise here
um and then finally this is joshua
bingio talking about okay you know do
your machine learning community you know
uh what if we had the right causal
structure in our neural networks um and
the claim is that basically
if you have these kind of independent
mechanisms in your causal you know in
your causal mechanism
that you'll be able to
learn with many fewer samples that's
referred to as sample complexity
and it'll be more robust to things like
uh you know what's called distribution
shift or you know domain shift and
things like this
the idea that if like the the data that
you use for training is not exactly the
same as the data that you're trying to
apply it to in the real world it'll be
more robust and you see various
discussion from other you know
luminaries and machine learning um so
these are very much on people's mind uh
these topics are very much on people's
mind and what i'm interested in
is the fact that the
the kind of traditional direction that's
coming from physics and this kind of
modern machine learning
uh thinking is is coming together at the
same time and the role of causality is
very important so i already mentioned
basically this idea of
of trying to uh you know the the
importance of machine learning for
simulation based inference but you also
see this idea that if you can
incorporate what you know about the data
generating process into the machine
learning models themselves uh that that
can basically help with sample
complexity and it's kind of a path
towards how ai might actually start to
learn the underlying causal mechanism
which i think is on the path towards ai
generating hypotheses and designing
experiments
um
and um
and then lastly i just say that there's
going back to some of
john woodward's points is that this this
way of framing it and thinking about it
allows you to basically do experiments
uh where you can the simulators
basically they have a you know ground
truth data generating process where
you're not arguing about what the actual
causal story is because it's right there
in front of you in your computer program
and then you can look to see what kind
of you know how effective is it to
impose this type of inductive bias on
the model and uh and how much does that
help uh in terms of these like normative
aspects about
that bring together
causation and causal reasoning
and uh with that i will say thank you
and remind you that uh next week on uh
wednesday at 4 p.m i have a follow-up
discussion with zinna and i'm looking
forward to that very much thank you
very much
thank you uh so much kyle for that
absolutely fantastic talk
um very very clear exposition and i
really appreciate the fact that you put
effort into combining and putting
together the various threads that
previous speakers and the directions
that
previous speakers in the series have
taken to address these issues i
personally really appreciated your
showing the difference
uh differences in the meaning of uh
causality the different meanings of
causality uh
that
that have been used and how they
actually relate to each other so there
are questions uh lining up in the chat
but i um i'm jumping with one question
myself so i'm gonna take this
first which is so um um i i loved your
sort of clarifying um the process of
inference and how
um in a domain like physics the known
laws actually guide us and how
replicating that um so i was wondering
so in terms of new discoveries right so
suppose there's a hitherto unknown
conservation law
and
because of the um you know because we
are moving using our domain knowledge to
come up with a suitable summary
statistic and you know just following
the language of the examples
in physics right
so is it completely impossible because
our summary statistic is limited because
it's defined entirely by what is known
prior knowledge
that something that is either too
unknown
will actually be mystic how would you
capture i want to understand how you
could open up discovery space
yeah no that's a great question so i
think you know the typical way that
we've gone around gone about designing
summary statistics has been guided by
how we think the data you know like you
know our assumptions about what's
actually going on or or there's a
hypothesis we don't know if it's true or
not but if it were true it has the
following consequences and that and we
can use that as a guide for designing a
summary that's going to be very powerful
right um
but uh but there are other approaches
that you can use to to kind of take the
height it's essentially like data
compression you have high dimensional
data and you're going to distill it down
to some lower dimensional thing and uh
and you'll discard some information on
the way
that's fine i mean these summary
statistics that we use in particle
physics are good for one task but
they're not good for other tasks so it's
not not surprising that you're going to
throw away a lot of data um but there
are certainly approaches
where you try to
uh just you know
sort of
learn in machine learning they would be
referred to as a representation of the
data you have
the full data and then you have some
representation that will capture some
pieces of information but not others
right and so um
so the there are all sorts of approaches
including unsupervised learning or even
what i was talking about
and what i showed uh with where we were
using neural network that neural network
surrogate in some sense is the learned
summary statistic
um but it's again it's learned because
it's targeting a specific hypothesis if
you wanted to do it in a way that's like
like i think the essence of your
question where you're not assuming the
hypothesis but you're trying to learn
from data what would that look like and
there certainly are various approaches
that are coming out now things that are
related to like anomaly detection and
stuff like that we try to
essentially learn some representation
which is good at capturing what most of
the data looks like and then you look
for something unusual and some
some sense of unusual um you know
there's progress there but it's it's you
know it's a it's a bit of a can of worms
if you wanted to discover something like
a uh a symmetry
you know i think uh there are definitely
works there to try to you know how could
you discover them you know one of them
is you basically
sort of enumerate a bunch of
possibilities and then you basically
right yeah
it turns into yeah
but you know you have to still start
with some you know prior um expectation
maybe it's even as silly as dimensional
analysis or something right but you have
to just brute force
your possibilities
um yeah that's uh
that's uh uh that's that's pretty clear
so hey let me move on to the first
question which is somewhat related it's
from freddost what if we want to look at
physics beyond the standard model where
the theory is in uncharted uh territory
in a manner of speaking so how do we
hunt for these signatures
yeah no exactly so i think the
it's a question that comes up a lot in
this talk which is like you know well
you know that's great and all but i want
to learn something that's beyond my
simulator you know like i want to learn
new physics so so one thing that's
important to realize is that
we don't just have a simulator for like
a standard model
we have simulators for
basically all of the crazy thoughts that
theorists have come up with over the
last you know decades so so we have a a
formalism that's that's uh that's kind
of you know general purpose and we we
describe essentially every
you know new physics theory that we can
think of gets described in that
formalism and the tools that we have and
allow us to make predictions of what we
would expect the data to look like for
kind of any theory in that that space of
theories now you could say i want to go
even beyond that and ask about
theories that you know that are not
expressed in that formalism um and then
and uh um and then you know i guess what
to say
essentially all kinds of inference are
going to be done at some point in the
context of a model right so you need
some notion of saying what do you think
the data is going to look like uh and uh
and so and that doesn't have to be
expressed in the language of quantum
field theory it could be a very um
empirically motivated way like signature
based like what if there's a bump in the
data or what's the data does this you
know it doesn't have to be based on
quantum field theory or something and so
then you can say um well i don't know
exactly what the bump looks like but can
you search for any any bump or any sharp
feature or does you know does it ever
have any kind of uh if you if you don't
say add some other assumption you just
say anything other than the standard
model then you get you open yourself up
to a bunch of possibilities that people
don't want to take seriously like you
know electronic noise in your detector
that has no kind of structure to it that
no one no physicist would look like and
be like new physics they'd just be like
i've got a cable that's loose or
something you know so so uh but by
trying to figure out how to balance that
between very well specified
theories that are so narrow that they
maybe seem uninteresting and a
completely open ended uh you know could
be anything where you have no power the
finding that trade-off is is challenging
and so coming up with a way to describe
theories in some kind of effective way
that people are happy with that
maintains some power is is
you know it's kind of a transition
that's happening i mean it's it's an old
problem it's a classic problem in
statistics but it's renewed it has
renewed energy in the context of machine
learning now
um thank you very much
the next question is from uh lee hao um
lihar muyan in my understanding the
state-of-the-art machine learning
algorithms really act like a black box
it's very difficult to interpret why the
algorithm actually works
would this reduce the power of ml
inferences
uh by
keeping it a black box or by making
something that's not about the
this meaning what i'm preferring yeah
well i think that yeah so
let's see what to say so you know that
that general idea of adding structure to
your architecture your model you know
was referred to as inductive bias right
so why is that term used well inductive
because you're kind of adding some
structure to the model to try to you
know because you're
but but the the bias part is because
you're not giving you're not saying as
an equal playing field to all possible
scenarios that the data could look like
anything you're saying i think the data
has some kind of
is organized in some way it has some
type of structure and when you impose
that
then you are kind of you know you're
you're favoring yourself in that
direction and so you're kind of biasing
yourself in that way now if the thing if
the reality actually has that structure
then you're kind of you're fine like if
the reality is there if reality is not
quite in that family of things then then
maybe you have a bit of a problem um but
uh but generally you know if you can
impose that structure and it's like the
right thing you're good of course you
don't know if it's right or not so it's
a tough question to answer generally um
but uh the other thing to say is if you
think about situations like there have
been papers you know i referred to some
of the work by peter battalion company
and uh there's a recent paper by miles
kramer no relationship uh who who's
looking at for instance planets moving
around and trying to infer what's the
what is the gravitational law um and
we've done some some work like that
those kinds of models you can
use what are called graph neural
networks where the nodes of the graph
are things that have physical meaning
like planets or particles or atoms
and the edges between them have physical
meaning like force between two planets
or something like that and in that sense
you know you're kind of doing the hard
work for for the machine learning like
you know the machine learning algorithm
didn't know what planets were or that it
wasn't some like linear combination of
planets that should be a node it said
like each planet should be a node and
there should be a you know a one-way
bi-directional relationship that's
symmetric and all sorts of things
and so you you impose all that inductive
bias but in that problem you think it's
right and if you do that it just helps
tremendously right if you take that away
you could in principle get there but
you're going to need a lot more data
before you you know perform well great
thank you um and there's of course um a
really uh profound question from uh
brian
uh thanks for this really fun and
accessible talk kyle could you talk a
little bit about what you've been
thinking regarding the implications for
epistemology and the limits of human
knowledge or information acquisition
yeah that's a good one um yeah i mean i
think well what to say
i i
you know i'm not i'm not like a trained
philosopher so probably everything i
will say will sound like you know naive
and et cetera but i i do often like to
think of it in terms of
you know if some alien civilization came
and landed uh it would be clear that
they are you know if they have the
fantasy spaceships and stuff it's clear
they have advanced technology you're not
going to be arguing about if they're
intelligent or not you know um and uh
and it's clear that they probably have
some notion of science or they probably
wouldn't have gotten there you know and
uh and so compared to other areas where
you like with you know ai human level
aai where you're arguing about what does
it mean to be intelligent it's like this
starting this framing you're kind of not
it's a very uh understandable notion for
i think most people that yes they're
intelligent they've got some notion of
science and then you imagine starting
some conversation with them you know you
don't you don't have a line language
it's you know it's not star trek uh but
uh but you know say you can figure that
part out then there's gonna be a
question of like does the ontology that
they have
like align with ontology that we have at
all
or do they have like a totally different
way of thinking about everything you
know how did that come to be
and uh
and and i think that's a you know it's
an interesting question it's not clear
and then when you then use that way of
thinking about it with the conversation
towards like robot scientists and ai
like you know is there any expectation
that
some ai type thing like should it be
interpretable to humans
well you know i don't know
as long as humans are in the process of
designing experiments and doing
hypothesis generation it's pretty
important that we can understand what
happens for the current experiment that
we're doing and if we somehow see that
and have like really black box neural
networks and things
that maybe solve the problem we're on
today really really well but if
something goes wrong we don't know what
to do next uh then the whole way in
which we aggregate knowledge in the the
scientific enterprise up until then is
going to be kind of uh
you know dramatically affected and i
think that would probably not go well uh
but i i do see uh you know and you're
already starting to see it in like
self-driving labs for chemistry and
stuff like that you have kind of closed
loop systems
usually only in pretty confined
uh settings where that's effective
uh but uh but yeah i think it's it's a
fascinating question um
i don't know that i really answered it
but
you know um a sort of a related um a
thread that occurs to me um from from uh
what you've said uh kyle
is it you know domain knowledge in uh in
many ways um is traded off with the
amount of data right so if you don't
have domain knowledge i mean is it is it
really true that having an infinite
amount of data means that you don't
actually need domain knowledge
oh yeah so that's interesting well one
thing that you know i mentioned earlier
this like ladder of causation and that
so the
even if you have an infinite amount of
data and you have like infinite
computing power um you know you can
basically any probabilistic question
that you want to answer
uh but you know that's that's that can
be expressed as like a joint
distribution or a marginal or something
like that you have access to all of that
uh you know you can do all sorts of
things but you can only answer questions
in the lowest rung of the causal
hierarchy if you ever want to ask what
would happen if i intervene you're just
not going to be able to answer that on
principle so uh yeah so i don't think
you know that's why i don't think data
like this whole data-driven thing yeah
it's kind of like kind of missing uh
pretty
right i mean this is where i was going
right because in our fields for example
in astronomy cosmology particle physics
i mean we are really hurtling towards
the you know just procuring huge amounts
of data somehow thinking that that is
going to be
sort of the resolution in providing
deeper insights into the theory because
there are limits there are limits that
yeah i mean it generally helps
but yeah it you know at the lhc
um people use this term data driven
analysis techniques a lot what's
interesting is if you look there
um a lot of times what happens is that
there's some clever
insight about how you can reuse the data
that has some characteristics and then
uh sort of use it to extrapolate to what
it would look like in a different
setting um but the only way that you're
able to do that is because we think oh
well if i take out the electron and
replace it with the muon and then i have
this following relationship and you
assume everything else is not unchanged
and all sorts of stuff so that looks a
lot like causality you know like all of
those kinds of operations
are
kind of uh
using causal structure uh the physicists
have learned to do this
knowledge of causes and structures but
we don't usually describe it in those
languages we don't talk we don't use the
language of causal inference when we do
it um
i think sean has an urgent hand up there
are many more questions but did you want
to
speak up or
i think you may have to type in the chat
charm
because we are in the webinar format
and also priya we have zenna has
contributed something in the chat i
think because of his host privileges he
wasn't able to
go into the q a
i see the question i don't know yeah go
ahead and ask
i think you can unmute yourself i can i
can maybe well we could just read it so
it says a question if i may you
mentioned that reality seems to be
striated so that it can be understood at
different levels of abstraction
could it be instead that this is more
about human minds than the world
and more pragmatically do you have
thoughts of model representation that
could capture
multiple different abstractions
simultaneously yeah that's a great
question um now i mean when you get into
you know i mean this is a super
philosophical question i mean there's a
you know like
there's a question like to the extent
there are cells and organs and you know
an individual you know and then there
and then like a populations of some
species you know it's to me you know i
guess i'm a bit of a realist there and
that that that striation seems to be
pretty
real um in a in a in a in a physics
context you know you can go between
things like quarks uh to things like
protons and neutrons to atoms and and uh
you know it could be that that's all uh
you know an illusion but it's certainly
a very
effective description has worked across
wildly different kinds of experiments so
it's a it's a it's a very effective
abstraction um and again i i'm certainly
a bit of a
realist there but like you know i'm open
to the
the fact that it's you know that
the broader philosophical discussions
there but in a in a in a practical sense
um
you know whether those things are really
real or not the extent that humans you
know use them as a tool to make
predictions about things has certainly
empirically
served us very well in navigating the
world and uh and and we you know have
success after success after success and
and using that those relationships to
organize things um and i think you know
individual humans it certainly
seems to me uh you know i'm not a
cognitive scientist that we but that we
you know you read well you know what
many cognitive scientists are saying is
that this does seem to be how we're
organizing the world and that our
success as a species has a lot to do
with being able to kind of
pick the appropriate abstraction and re
do reasoning very efficiently
using it i think then the last part of
your question to me is that you know the
the part that's the most compelling
currently is how do we build that into
some kind of ai machine learning like
architecture um i think in the context
of you know step one is how do you do
the first even before like
different layers at one particular layer
how do you include that bias and i think
that's where you see things like graph
neural networks uh you know for certain
things where you can really point to
individual things like planets and stuff
like that you know it's very clear how
to do it and it works really well uh a
research direction that i think is
interesting is like
what if you didn't do that by hand you
know how hard would it be to like if you
took the data and reorganized it in some
way and then you said okay you know you
want some meta machine learning
algorithms to figure out like what are
the
objects in your ontology to attach to
nodes in a graph and what the edges mean
and how you would you know do that in
some more automated way you know that's
interesting there's work that's going on
about dynamically building graph neural
networks which is in that direction and
then there is the idea of if you have a
graph like course draining it so that
you have
and that looks you know it looks sort of
like the pooling operations you see in a
convolutional neural network so there
are certainly ideas and there are people
exploring that and i have you know
trying to do some work like that on my
own um and i think it's uh
that's super
super interesting and you know there are
various people playing around in that
area right now yeah no i mean uh asana
this is something um we hope to talk
more about um um during your
presentation uh or next uh next
wednesday but kyle related to this i
have this
little aside related which is i mean
isn't it true that when we are coarse
graining uh a system in physics for
example uh it's very intentional right i
mean we are core screening because we
know that at a certain level of
abstraction we will have additional
information that we can use additional
priors that can play into we know a new
set of rules a new distribution a form
for a distribution you know maxwellian
that will work for the ensemble right so
the core screening is always because we
do already have prior information
about um
how a system will look when we
i would say you know yes and no i think
there's i would say that
that you know if you look at major
advances in science a lot of times it's
like the fact that uh uh you you're able
to first identify here is a scale
where there is a an effect you know
there is going to be a useful
description and there's going to be some
kind of laws that describe what's going
on and then you need to kind of have
some ontology of what are the right like
degrees of freedom or the right kinds of
objects to even talk about at that scale
and then what do their interactions look
like and then you know what are the laws
that describe that scale and that
sometimes that just happens kind of on
its own you know at that level but when
those things happen they're really
important right those are like major
major events
in science right and then if you can and
then in the reductionist type picture if
you can
then tie it back to the lower level
scale and say like this is how they're
related like that's even like that's a
another i mean these are all like nobel
prize
you know
events and so part of what i think is so
profound about the simulation basis
inference thing
is that you start off it's kind of
allows you a way to maybe bootstrap that
process you start with the simulator at
one scale you know what's going on
then there are some emergent phenomena
that are really complicated you don't
know what they are but through learning
you're able to find kind of what are the
right summaries uh coarse graining you
know whatever that kind of identify the
the new degrees of freedom right you
don't have a name for them yet you know
you know but they're the new kind of
effective degrees of freedom at that
coarse grain scale and then if you can
just end up learning like laws on those
new you know core strain degrees of
freedom then you can lift up and operate
very very quickly
compared to the almost sounds like you
know this is a completely alternative
it's not quite a demystification of the
standard process of discovery but almost
a brand new way for discovery i mean at
least it feels that way right yeah it
just seems like there's potentially a
path to kind of systematically uh
hop between like you know or maybe you
already know the right scale for
whatever reason but you don't know how
they're related
and you can simulate you know so uh and
so they're definitely you know well we
have some work going on that's basically
trying to do exactly that like you know
i i know how to simulate one scale i
know there's a
phenomena emerge at a different scale so
i can predict them and if it doesn't
require like exponential amount of
computing time then i can like get
enough data where i can try to like
learn in that relationship and that's
that's really compelling i
think thanks uh so jeremy zucker has the
next question what do you recommend as
the best python library for performing
simulation based inference
uh yeah it's a good question something
else are there some any probabilistic
programming languages that can do
simulation based inference
yeah i can give a quick quick guide to
this without getting too into the weeds
so there's a tool called sbi which
stands for simulation-based inference
it's kind of like a nice general purpose
uh python wrapper type of
approach um
so you have a way to kind of
interface whatever simulator you have to
it
you know generates data does the machine
learning components and then you can do
inference
and it implements several different
techniques right so elfie is kind of
uh was more tied to one specific
technique um
and so uh yeah so the
which is fine but it's it's sort of less
of a toolkit in general um and then you
mentioned eight aluminum
yeah so that was a project that i was
involved in so the there's a kind of
important distinction there which i
didn't you know get into but if you
remember this diagram that i drew that
sort of had parameters on the you know
on the left uh data on the right and in
the middle there were latent variables
um what uh the ada loomis and pi prob uh
this probabilistic programming
approach
uh it doesn't try to sort of bypass the
latent variables and go to straight to
the parameters it actually gives you the
capability to do inference on the latent
variables itself but that's a much
harder problem it's a much more
complicated thing to try to infer
so if you want to try to do that that's
the tool for you just know that uh
it's a lot harder so in that adalumus
work we like use supercomputers and
stuff like that uh in other contexts
that's not uh required but uh kind of
depends on your problem
great thank you um so i i guess uh his
next question is sean sanders how much
of this can be extended to body of
social phenomena
yeah it's a good question i mean i think
well i mean
i i had this discussion once before with
like you know
a lot of the way that the simulation
based inference stuff is set up uh you
need to be able to generate data
conditioned on or given
some i said parameter but it could be
given some whatever you want so you
could for instance
look at the text of tweets given a
certain hashtag
you know and that could be like a
political hashtag or it could be you
know the use of some emoji or you know
something like you know your favorite
sports team or something like that right
so um so it doesn't actually have to be
a simulator you just need a
data generating process that you can
condition on
and so that makes it interesting because
you have the opportunity to realize what
i was talking about when you have real
world data generation
process um so also like for instance i
showed this toy um you know i can just
generate data from this toy over and
over and over it doesn't have to be a
simulator you know i can use the actual
physical system to generate the data and
use it and use all the same methodology
that i described so i think there's a
you know there's an opportunity to use
that and all sorts of different like
social contexts and things like that
obviously if you're going to go down
that road you should
take a moment to think about the ethics
of what you're doing and
and all of the things uh you know those
are important considerations but in
terms of the methodology itself there's
certainly uh
opportunities great thank you very much
so the next question is from michael
churchill for simulation based inference
what are the prospects
for working with very very expensive
simulators like exascale computer
computing
yeah so that's a good also really good
question so the in the context of large
hadron collider you know the real
collisions are happening about 40
million times a second but to simulate
one collision takes about 10 minutes so
there's like an enormous uh you know
gap between how long but 10 minutes
doesn't sound that bad and you can you
can run it on a fairly normal computer
and we have a lot of computers
um so it's expensive but it's doable um
if you wanted to go into a situation
like for instance uh
you look at the waveforms that come
inside of the ligo the gravitational
wave detector
then you want to predict what those
waveforms look like
given
uh some black hole uh you know merger
that that simulation
you know at one point requires numerical
relativity and all sorts of stuff or
other then there's you know others other
phases where you can do that
faster but it's still pretty expensive
and that's to simulate the waveform for
like one scenario and now you want to
scan through this fairly high
dimensional space that describes the
different ways the the black holes might
be oriented and their mass and spin and
all these things um
so that becomes expensive and uh um but
actually if you want to try to do normal
like bayesian inference in that setting
it's really really really expensive so
people have started using
likelihood free inference techniques or
simulation based inference techniques
basically to make that faster and so
what's nice is that you now have
situations you pay an upfront training
cost but once you're done with that you
have what's called an amortized
setup where you can do inference very
quickly so now there's systems where
they can look at the waveforms and
within microseconds tell you what the
posterior distribution on the sky is so
that you can slew your uh your your
telescopes um but there there's
definitely a lot of ongoing work about
yeah but that you know but kyle in that
case the training set is finite and
limited right so that there's a limited
set of waveforms that are real
gravitational waves right or you think
that when you say when you refer to the
training set do you mean like the full
set of all possible wave patterns or
like the ones that you know the ones
that you would get from like say running
a uh
simulation yeah
with whatever whatever approximations or
things you want to stick in your
simulator you know i don't want to get
into the beads of like close newtonian
stuff but like that um but uh
but the the wasn't going to say the
sorry the the um
the other thing there is that there's a
lot of work going on which is at the
beginning say like for that example you
don't know where on the sky
and you don't know like have any idea
what the mass of the black holes were
but you could you could make a very
rough scan at first and start to get an
idea and then refine with more
simulations in the relevant region and
so you have this kind of iterative
approach that uses this buzzword of kind
of active learning um and so there so
there's there are techniques that do
simulation-based inference where there's
like an active learning loop on the top
to try to make
the you know the
simulation as efficient as possible
because i mean these are cases where
doing uh you know having a library would
be too onerous it would be too
computational yeah trying to do it a
friend is like yeah not great and and
then earlier there's a question about
software this sbi tool for instance
implements these active learning
techniques um but there are some others
as well there's one called swift which
is pretty nice
um let me see if there are i think
there's one more uh question uh it's
jeremy zucker again if your simulator is
differentiable what methods exist to
speed up simulation based uh inference
yeah that's a great question um so i
mean without trying to give a shameless
plug or something we wrote a review uh
article about simulation based inference
techniques which may be a great article
by the way i can plug it it was in pnas
and i think it got me started uh
thinking about these issues
yeah but it was it was meant to be
fairly accessible but one of the things
that we spent some time there is saying
you know if you can open up your
simulator open up the black box and and
either instrument it with probabilistic
programming type of skills or if it's
differentiable
there's different ways it can be
differentiable it can be differentiable
in the sense of like input output
relationships or it can be
differentiable in the sense of the
probability of this
run of the simulator like what's the you
know derivative of that probability with
respect to the parameters of the
simulator so there are different kinds
of derivatives you can take and if you
can
you can you can take advantage of them
and and you can it can lead to a
dramatically more efficient learning so
we have a paper called uh you know
mining gold which talks about one type
of derivative and there we show that you
know for several problems that we were
looking at we could reduce the
simulation budget by like three orders
of magnitude so um so if you can take
those derivatives
things that we're taking you know
millions and tens of millions of
simulations turned into like a thousand
um so um so that's a pretty big
difference
great
thanks very much
um are there any other questions um
i'll just give give everyone another
minute if they want to type something up
or
hype up
um
if not
i mean to be continued i really look
forward
to the conversation between you and
zenna next wednesday
uh meanwhile uh thanks kyle for this
wonderful talk um really clear talk um
explaining um simulation based inference
to us and uh looking forward to seeing
you on wednesday
thanks everyone
yeah thanks everyone i also want to say
uh give a big thanks to tai and to guy
to liver for um helping with the
logistics and organizing
this talk and series
bye everyone and see you next wednesday